[Music]
my ticket long experience in the
business development sector has made me
realize you must know how to analyze
data and statistics to grow in your
career I plan to use the business
analytics strategic decision making
course which I did from IIT roorkee and
simply learned to pursue the Senior
Management roles
I have 12 years plus of experience in
business development currently I'm
planning to launch my own startup with
my friends recently I realized the
importance of data analytics for making
business decisions when I started my
career that technology was not that vast
and data is not readily available but
now it is I have also realized that
companies are looking for people with
the knowledge of machine learning so I
decided to choose a professional
certificate before choosing simply learn
I look for other platform too but the
course simple line provides covers
everything the association with IIT
rookie makes the certification
internationally recognized in fact my
journey will simply learn begin when I
took a course from skill up and I was
really impressed it made me confident
about choosing this course my experience
with simply learn has been amazing the
course is comprehensive and covers
subject of your interest it has R it has
python it has SQL but also something I
have always wanted to learn now I think
I'm ready to make a new beginning
I am going to change my domain from
Business Development to Big Data
learning and Analysis I am looking
forward handling project and handling
the profit and loss of my organization I
believe the learning from the course
will be very beneficial there I wanted
to be in a Senior Management role and I
believe this course will help me to get
there I want to thank my wife who has
been very supportive throughout my
journey I am happy that we have such an
amazing platform which actually quench
my thirst of learning you should never
stop learning